this is a production of Cornell
University
welcome to Cornell University's online
Cornell garden-based learning courses we
are thrilled about your interest in one
or more of our courses please take a few
moments to watch this video which
outlines several important details these
courses are designed for adult learners
who wish to expand their knowledge of
the topic often for their own enrichment
as with most online or autonomous
learning situations students typically
get out what they put into the course
the courses are non accredited and are
designed for non matriculated students
so you do not have to be enrolled at
Cornell University and the course does
not count towards college credit we find
that the most successful students are
those who are intrinsically motivated to
complete readings and assignments to
devote considerable time to coursework
and to communicate with your classmates
freely and often in an effort to get the
most from this course we welcome
participants from around the world and
find that international students at a
unique perspective to the course
environment each course is catered
toward a different skill level please
review the course syllabus for the
course you are interested in to learn
about the target audience for that
specific course for example organic
gardening is designed for beginners
while botanical illustration three
advanced techniques is designed for
those with greater mastery of the
subject area the courses are fully
online and students should have a basic
knowledge of how to use a computer and
have an openness around learning the
technology it is not necessary to have
previous experience with taking online
courses students will have access to the
course interface for the time frame of
the course much like a traditional
classroom in which once you leave the
room and the course is over when this
course is finished you are responsible
for keeping any records you wish since
the course is cleared or reset for the
next group of participants students who
complete all assignments will receive a
certificate of completion at the
conclusion of the course though specific
supplies will vary for each course
students must have a computer with
high-speed
access some courses also require a
device for scanning particular
assignment submissions please listen
carefully to our refund policy if you
choose to withdraw any time prior to the
end of the introductory period before
the start of Lesson one you can receive
a refund - a one hundred and fifty
dollar processing fee this fee applies
to each course dropped once week one has
begun we are unable to provide you with
a refund given that this course demands
a significant amount of time attention
and energy over an extended period of
time it is important to take steps in
advance of the program to ensure that
you have the necessary support
structures in place the estimated time
commitment varies for each online course
please review the course syllabus for
the course you are interested in to
learn about the estimated hours per week
most courses are six to eight weeks and
offer a blend of online and hands-on
learning each week's lessons will
contain a combination of selected
readings activities to carry out at home
reflective writing student discussion
forum prompts and optional additional
readings activities and resources
students submit their weekly assignments
before the stated deadline and the
instructor provides timely feedback
though the class is not live
participants are expected to keep up
with the weekly assignments and
discussions because the weekly topics
build on each other
skipping a topic one week will cause
some confusion it is a requirement to
engage in at least a full page of
reflective writing weekly while some
students initially balk at this most
appreciate how with time the reflection
helps to deepen their course experience
as John Dewey so famously said we do not
just learn from our experience but we
learn from reflecting on it the student
discussion forum is a way to share
resources and get to know one another
although sharing your work with others
is not required some students also
appreciate the chance to offer their
work for celebration and feedback from
others open dialog is encouraged
between the instructor and students
students are encouraged to contact their
course instructor with any questions
some courses have an introductory period
before the beginning of week one this is
a time for students to gain access
become familiar with the course
interface and practice doing a few
simple tasks such as posting an
introduction in the student discussion
forum successful students take time
during the introductory period to
carefully read all course materials and
become familiar with the nuances of the
course offering if you are taking
drawing watercolor or the advanced
techniques botanical illustration course
it is much better to spend a shorter
period of time each day on your
assignments then to power through an
occasionally four or five hour chunks of
time you will want to devote at least 12
to 15 hours per week and with increasing
hours you will gain more proficiency
you'll grow much more in scale with more
sessions and in addition stay on top of
the assignments though the assignments
are not difficult in fact they can be
enjoyable and relaxing there are many of
them it is important to keep your
expectations modest these are just six
week courses and remember the 10,000
hours rule of thumb it takes a long time
to gain mastery if you have additional
questions please review our frequently
asked questions page if you are unable
to find an answer there then please
email the relevant point of contact for
the course in question thank you for
watching this video and we hope to see
you in one of our future course
offerings this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu